we we realized that there was a need for  a more concerted effort to understand  genomic variation so the nih announced  its support of precision medicine in  2015 when then president obama in his  state of the union address described  precision medicine as an emerging  approach to disease prevention and  treatment that takes into account  people's individual variations in genes  environment and lifestyle  so this was accompanied by a publication  in the new england journal of medicine  written by then director of the nih  francis collins and past director of the  national cancer institute harold barmus  this perspective further supported the  convictions of president obama that  science offers great potential for  improving human health and this  officially launched the nih precision  medicine initiative in 2015.